[Music]
xavier is with us in huntington west
virginia hi xavier how are you
doing well sir thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
well i am in baby step two and i have
some very well meeting friends i was
actually in their wedding
and they got married and uh their their
kids call me young so i'm really close
to that family
and so when i found out that i was
becoming debt free
um they were really hesitant i have made
some stupid mistakes before so they're
they're uh really concerned that it may
not be the the best thing so how could i
explain to them in a logical way
that being debt free is possible it's
wise
and you can still have nice things even
though you may not have what you could
get with a loan or something like that
xavier do your friends pay your bills
no they do not then their opinion and
your personal finances don't matter and
i that hurts to hear but the truth is
the best way you can convince them is by
doing it
and you go yeah i became debt free 18
months later and here i am i get to live
the life i want i'm not held back by
debt and they go hold on
how'd you do that because right now it's
a theory to them right
right and it's a theory coming from a
guy with a bad track record on theories
you
right
not me right right exactly exactly
hey uh listen here's the thing
one of the ways that one of the things
we find when we study millionaires is
they will often tell us when we're
having conversations with them that
their breakthrough came
when they loved their friends and their
family but they no longer gave them a
vote
and i think i am right there yeah you
know i i think your friend loves you
i just think he's stupid about money
and i don't think you're gonna convince
him from the seat that you're sitting in
because you're not sitting in a seat of
credibility so george is right you go
get out of debt and you pile up some
money and you can tell him nothing about
what he needs to do but always just tell
him your story and go listen i paid off
everything and i don't have any payments
you know how that feels it's awesome i
feel so awesome on any payments and now
that i don't have any payments you know
what i've got money and i got money to
do this and i got money to do that
because i'm not paying it all out in
payments and it's just awesome and all
you could all you can do is talk about
you and then they'll go yeah but what
about me and go well i don't know i can
show you how to do it i guess but i'm
not going to tell you how to do it
because you you know i'm not that guy
that was you you're that guy
yeah i appreciate that thank you yeah so
i think that's what you do you just got
to go on and do it anyway um
and
you know
and hopefully they will you know it'll
be kind of a
it doesn't have to be snarky but it can
kind of be a toby keith moment like how
do you like me now you know
and um
you just kind of play that song in the
background and yeah
and you always say if if people are
think your financial plan is stupid
you're on the right track broke people
think your financial plan is off track
then you're right on track yeah that's
how you know you're winning that is
and
you know george the number of times i
mean i went to high school i grew up my
high school graduating class was 425
people
and um
i mean i'm old enough a few of them have
passed away now right but uh
but but um the
there's a
bunch of those folks i considered very
good friends
and i've kept up at moderate degrees
with several of them through the years
but the number of them that are
in my life once every six months today
um
two
you know and my in other words my
friends group has changed from my high
school well that's everybody right i'm
not different from anybody else that's
everyone if you're 60 years old and
you're still running around with your
old high school buddies that's a little
strange really it is it's unusual
it doesn't mean that you're a snob it
doesn't mean that they're snobs it
doesn't mean any of that it just means
people change people grow they move they
do different things and so this may be
one of the cases with xavier it may be
that this is the thing he was in their
wedding and i mean i got guys that was
in their wedding and i don't even know
where they are now you know and if
you've got emotional maturity i mean
i've got plenty of friends who disagree
with me financially we just don't talk
about finances there's a lot of other
things you can talk about we can still
be friends if we can't have a
disagreement and still be friends then
we aren't really friends exactly
um that's the other thing that goes with
it that's a good point i like that